they were always passive aggressive I
was the niceness was always fake I was
always calling it out with the Canadians
I was I was I banned from Canada aren't
you I was banned for 10 years the son of
a guns I had to get a lawyer to fight
these benefits
to go to Canada why because he's a real
American Girl
you must really like poutine no I didn't
and there was I was dating a chick and I
needed to see her family and um I demand
to be led into Canada I know I'm not
proud of that okay stop I just escaped
he like he he jumped over the wall and
was running so it feels like I'm
thinking like Einstein before Nazi
Germany fled Nazi Germany before they
started cracking on the Jews and what is
Peterson doing in Canada right now when
they're threatening to strip him of his
license first and I agree with you Tim I
don't think that his that his psychology
license is his crowning achievement even
close to it when history looks at Jordan
Peterson they'll remember the things he
said and things he did